now that we have a loaded image we need
to draw that image to the canvas via the
canvas draw image API this function
takes the image object itself as well as
the locations on the canvas that we'd
like to draw that image as you can see
there's some other parameters that draw
image takes don't worry about those just
yet for now you can leave those blank by
the way if you're ever interested in
finding out more about an API for html5
development make sure you check out
webplatform.org it's a nifty little
space where all your questions can be
answered for a next step why don't you
go ahead and fill in the onload function
that we defined earlier so there rather
than logging a message to the consult
instead it draws the image at pixel
location 192 by 192